it is so essential to stop and really
pay attention that ability to attend to
really take in what's happening can
spark ideas or directions that we
wouldn't have come upon if we hadn't
just slowed down and really paid
attention ben burtt is the sound
designer for many of the films that if
you think of films of the last 25 30
years you think Oh remember the sound of
Indiana Jones whip that's Ben Burtt I
remember the sound of the lightsabers
and Star Wars that's Benford he has
created the iconic sounds for so many
movies he's someone who is exquisitely
attuned to what his world sounds like
you may have seen wall-e and there's
this little robot in it called mo and he
said you know the basics for mo is my
shaver in the bathroom I thought that
sounds like wow and so he recorded the
shaver and he then manipulated it and
suddenly you have this little hilarious
character running around but came right
out of his bathroom what he said was
even if it's been transmuted into
something new we recognize the origins
in what's around us the ability of Ben
Burtt to really pay attention to what's
around him to reconvene and rethink
things so suddenly is quite wonderful